[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con aquí en
france 24 mi nombre es liliana valencia
hoy hablaremos del informe de la
organización reporteros sin fronteras
que lista a 37 personalidades del mundo
a los que acusa a ejercer una represión
masiva de la libertad de prensa y los
llama tiranos
nos acompaña en manuel colombi director
regional para américa latina de
reporteros sin fronteras rsf gracias por
estar con nosotros aquí en real 24
cuéntanos mohamed bin salman el príncipe
heredero de arabia saudita es una de las
nuevas incorporaciones de esta lista de
tiranos pues se sospecha que estaría
atrás del asesinato en 2018 el
periodista yamaha jog y que significó
este crimen para el periodismo a nivel
internacional y se imaginó este un
escenario similar a ese en nuestros días
bueno ustedes conocen ese caso terrible
del asesinato de la marca su guía que ha
sido literalmente des encarnizados
dentro de la embajada
sabemos sí que todo indica que el
principio tiene responsabilidad en este
caso pero la justicia local e
internacional hasta la fecha no logró
abrir una investigación para encontrar
las pruebas necesarias para que él sea
oficialmente ha responsabilizado por ese
crimen es un crimen terrible es una
señal terrible para los otros países
vecinos es de alguna forma el hecho de
que esté este crimen hasta ahora quede
impune es una señal terrible y dice que
se puede sí silenciar los periodistas de
esa manera tan terrible que no no va a
pasar nada así que es un caso
prioritario para reporteros sin
fronteras y seguiremos denunciando
la responsabilidad del estado de
verdadera vía saudita en este en este
caso absolutamente horrible esta es la
primera vez en 20 años que un líder de
la unión europea figura en esta lista se
trata de víctor orbán primer ministro de
hungría que supone esto para la libertad
de expresión en el continente europeo
lo que está pasando también para la
prensa dependiente de hungría es
gravísimo necesitamos mostrarlo y
sensibilizar la comunidad internacional
sobre esa situación se trata no hay
otras palabras de una una cacería de una
tentativa de ciencia absolutamente todos
los periodistas críticos del gobierno a
través de encasillamientos a través de
prácticas de otros tiempos y es
importante solidarizarse con los pocos
pero dices dependientes que van
denunciando la corrupción del gobierno
que van haciendo también un trabajo de
información así que en una región donde
tenemos un nivel de libertad de prensa
bastante bueno el caso de hombría nos
llama la atención y se volvió también un
país prioritario para nosotros es
fundamental decir que es casi imposible
ahora trabajar como periodista
independiente en este país y hay un
montón también de periodistas que tienen
que salir de la región para seguir
trabajando vamos a decir normalmente y
es también la primera vez que dos
mujeres entran en esta lista como
enemigas de la libertad de expresión
cuéntenos quiénes son y por qué hacen
parte de este
bueno una de la de ellas perdón
descarrilan
la jefa de la jefa ejecutiva de regiones
ni práctica especial de hong kong desde
2007 2017 que ella ha demostrado ser una
marioneta en manos del presidente chino
xi jinping y ahora que la apoya
abiertamente las políticas liberticidas
del mandatario chino que han llevado a
la desaparición el 24 de junio del
principal diario independiente de hong
kong apple daily
y encarcelamiento de su fundador jimmy
lines que fue el ganador de varios
premios e incluso el premio de libertad
de prensa debe ser la segunda
depredadora es sheikh hasina que
gobierna en bangladesh desde 2009 la
hija del héroe de la independencia
aprobó en 2018 una ley de seguridad
digital que ha llevado a juicio a más de
70 periodistas y blogueros en el país
así que son efectivamente las nuevas
depredadores de la libertad en ese nuevo
ranking y lo lamentamos obviamente
pues agradecemos este espacio con
emanuel y colombi director regional para
américa latina de reporteros sin
fronteras hablando de este listado de 37
personalidades que irían en contra de la
libertad de expresión a nivel global
finalizamos por ahora pero ustedes
pueden continuar con más en nuestra
página web france24 punto com para
ampliar la información de américa latina
y el mundo quédense con nosotros nos
vemos más adelante
[Música]